good afternoon for those of you who were
not there this morning my name is Julian
Lucia
I've been nine years with Google worked
the last four years alongside the
engineering security and compliance
teams in in California just back in
Brussels now located from Brussels and
from Brussels I supports the engagement
towards regulators towards large
prospects or very sensitive prospects
you know the prospects with handling
very sensitive data even if they're not
large and I facilitate the communication
between the European markets and the and
the teams abroad what I what I want to
do in this session is go deeper into the
summary message that I try to compile
into ten minutes this morning so sorry
for those of you of weather already this
morning you will there will be some
repeats but in each time I will go
deeper and my objective is to share with
you some of the talking points some of
the narratives that we use when we talk
to you know these people these senior
decision-makers that we need to help
shift and nudge you know in the
direction of the cloud so there will be
some of that I will be addressing also
some of the key messages that need to be
heard in the market I you know I have
more content than then is needed I'll
try to keep it to 35 minutes and keep
ten minutes for questions so as I talk
and you have questions feel free to note
them down and I'll be happy to take
questions even though this is a tricky
exercise in public with a large crowd
there's always someone that has the
curricular question than the other but
I'm happy to to go in that direction so
I will do this in two steps
the first step will be for me to go into
the technology and then I will cover
more the compliance side of things
because it's a very important topic here
in Europe before I start I'm going to
ask you to do a short visualization
exercise
if you if you're in meditation you know
what visualization is you close your
eyes and for a few seconds you just
picture for yourself that one person in
your family your close group of friends
that is still today you know saving all
of his money his lifelong savings under
a mattress in his bedroom her bedroom
and possibly you know a shotgun in the
living room and you close your eyes and
you think about that person we all have
that person in our family is a group of
friends you know behaving that way or
maybe we don't because nobody does that
anymore and the reason I'm using this
little trick is because I want to
introduce a fact now that an increasing
number of people are making a parallel
between what is happening with the cloud
today with what has been happening with
the bank's world in the banking
revolution 100 250 years ago what the
banks did and managed to do over a quite
long period of time they managed to
convince every single one of us to take
the most valuable belongings they had
away from these silos of you know
pairings and bring this into what was
then called capital and what capital
allowed to do was absolutely unthinkable
before capital was created motorways
skyscrapers research program quest to
the moon you name it this was all made
possible because of capital what is
happening with data today and with the
cloud today is very similar gradually we
receive the guarantees we receive the
commitments we grow up with the idea
that it is thinkable to take away the
information that is very secure in these
you know in these small silos and we
agreed to bring it together in these big
amounts of data hosted in the cloud and
this allows for ideas to happen that
we're completely unthinkable even a few
months ago I remember presenting on
driverless cars in Europe three years
ago you had people laughing in
nobody laughs about drivers of cars
anymore and and these things are coming
you know machine learning virtual
reality this is all these are all new
technologies new ideas that are powered
by the cloud made possible by the cloud
the banks brought something else than
capital they brought security and today
we cloud providers stand Boulder I would
say that they would stand a couple of
years back saying we can play a similar
role to what banks have played you know
when it comes to increase the security
of the data and there are a couple of
technical reasons for this that I
touched upon this morning that I want to
go a little bit deeper on this afternoon
then as was mentioned this morning you
will all be there thinking it's all fine
and good I understand you know Google
has the resource and the capacities to
protect the data but I still don't trust
you and so this is where I will go more
into details about what are the tools
what are the clauses what are the
information that you need to engage into
these discussions with yourself with
your stakeholders with your customers
and you know see how long it takes but
progress in that direction
to decide whether or not you want to
move to the cloud if I manage time well
I will have the time to share with you
more tools maybe go a little bit deeper
into the tools that I quickly snap this
morning that can help your organization
be more compliant and get ready for the
GDP are among others I also want to
share a few of the personal tools that
you can activate right now by the end of
the day or you know certainly during the
weekend on your own account to
significantly increase your security
posture and these are tools that are
available on the consumer world of
Google but are easily activated on the
organization side and so your
administrator or yourself can
activate this for your organization this
process of assessing deeply you know the
technical capabilities in terms of
security and then building the trust and
this you know within the stakeholders to
decide to move to the cloud is not the
process that you will pioneer into I
don't know if this is English but if
that you will pioneer okay today Google
serves six million organizations three
million of them are NGOs education
organizations the three other million
are commercial organization paying the
licenses and you recognize on these
slides already names of companies that
are handling extremely sensitive
information the one that we engage a lot
with at the moment we do joint events
and we try to evangelize this PwC PwC
you know is rolling out one hundred to
two hundred thousand users at the moment
across the world and they're handling
you know how sensitive how more
sensitive can you be then you know tax
information from from your from your
customers
you see names like child tribes Deloitte
The Economist is an interesting example
you know the source the life and death
of some of the sources being handled
there depends on the security of the
data and how well it is managed when
when we present in in the south of
Europe I like to bring up the example of
la mano de Lamont is one of the you know
dailies that has the most critical
editorial line on Google and yet they
are using G suite today to do to work
airburst is another good example there
are some names that are not on this
slide and there's one in particular that
is very very good example and I normally
we don't talk about them because we
don't have the marketing rights but they
blogged about it a few months ago so I
just now refer to the blog and I
encourage you to Google UK Cabinet
Office okay so the the the the team of
the Prime Minister of the United Kingdom
is using G sweet for a year and a half
now and they are very happy about it
they were so happy they blogged about it
and you know this is to give you an idea
of the level of security in the level of
privacy commitments these platforms in
general these are all Google example
these are all Google customers but this
is the level of security that cloud
providers have been able to give now to
their to their customers so going into
security itself you know in the first
part of the talk and trying to
understand what it is that makes cloud
platform in such bringing puts cloud
platforms in such a positive spot when
it comes to security I talked about this
model this morning you know assess the
capability to anticipate assess the
capability to defend and assess the
capability to react as a model that is
widely used across the security industry
to assess the security of any system
would it be an IT system or an IT system
and I mentioned the facts you know that
Google operates these seven platforms
with more than a billion users allowing
us to test these platforms very very
broadly if you think of what the
business model has been for the last 18
years of Google it has been to go around
the web and make a copy of the entire
web for some parts of it close to real
time and this copy is being brought to
our data centers it is being indexed and
the search results are delivered in a
few milliseconds so of course the
indexing doesn't it doesn't happen on
the live web it happens on the copy and
we deliver the search results on this on
this copy this gives you the idea of how
much we know about what is fantastic
about the web and that we share with you
immediately okay in terms of rough
search results also gives you an idea of
all that we know that is terrible about
the web that we also share with you we
share this in specific services the most
famous is called Safe Browsing it's a
package service in which we encapsulate
this data this information about the
different web sites and what they
contain the
be harmful and this service is shared
with mozilla and safari and so the most
most of the web browsers use that
information to protect you when you are
going to enter a harmful web site you
will receive a message that tells you
caution if you proceed beyond you know
this is good could be harmful to your to
your to your computer normally when
there are no spots I scan the audience
and I try to spot the people going yes
yes yes because then I know who is going
on these sites but here I have the spots
so I can't see anything I talked about
safety net this morning out of the two
billion Android devices 400 million
polled daily to gather the health
information and paint that landscape the
threat landscape you might know that
Google Play is a fully fledged payment
platform completely PCI DSS compliant
that handles you know the payment of
more than a billion user and Gmail
serves tens of thousands of doctors and
you know medical practitioners around
the world today so it has to be
compliant it had to comply with very
stringent health care regulation namely
the HIPAA regulation the United States
that is very demanding so this gives you
an idea of how this platform is being
tests tested and and allows us to gather
so much information out of all that
information there is one clear direction
that is important to keep in mind if you
try to figure out what is the direction
that the Google security teams are one
of the important direction that the
Google security teams are trying to
follow and it is summarized by this
slide it's public information but we
have similar data you know in our in our
logs almost all successful incidents
make use of a vulnerability that is
older than one year that means that the
problem lies with us users us
intermediate users administrators being
overwhelmed with the complexity of
having to constantly update patch keep
everything updated and under control and
even if your teams and your security
teams with an infinite budget and access
to
you know great research resources and
hire the best security researchers in
the country in the world you know you're
fighting an uphill battle because
two-thirds of the incidents make use of
login credentials that have been shared
by your users you know willingly and the
reason for this is according to this
public data it requires less than eight
emails to your organization to acquire
the login information of one of your
employees we ran a survey in 2014 with
the University of San Diego and our
results for the last data was 43%
there's actually less than three
well well-crafted emails to gather the
login credential of a of one of your
employees so what does that mean for
large cloud platforms in general and the
mission that the Google security teams
one of the direction the Google security
and set for yourself is that we must use
our capabilities the technical
capabilities that we have to offload
part of that complexity from the user we
must resolve that complexity problem
without imposing any trade-off on the
convenience that you have been used to
have on your on your devices or on your
systems because you know we all know
that the least trade-off and convenience
that is being asked you just try to go
around the security I I notice it with
myself and was it everybody you know it
just requires it's just a couple of
seconds more you know that you need each
time you log in and then you will try to
avoid that that threshold so how can
large cloud platforms develop systems
that solve this complexity and avoid the
the trade of forcing for a trade-off
so I touched upon the basics here I want
to go a little bit more in the detail I
touched upon the basic this morning I
want a little bit more a little bit more
in the details so these infrastructures
will build from a blank slate you know
not having to cope with the complexity
but of course they grew up being very
complex systems I mentioned you know
these to Bill
lines of codes and 50,000 engineer or
30,000 engineers
creating 50,000 change requests per day
and I mentioned intelligent automation
you know handling all this and being
able to manage all this if you want to
picture for yourself a security problem
that has been solved by that kind of
intimation you think about how you were
using emails at the end of the 90s and
you remember how email was going to die
email was unusable because of spam there
was so much spam email was a dead tool
if you're using Gmail today you have
less than 0.01% of spam in your inbox
and the reason for this is that these
systems are reading your emails and have
become very very good at predicting what
is relevant what is not relevant for you
what is threatening what is not
threatening to you and when you know
that spam is one of the biggest vectors
for distribution of malware this is a
significant win actually one of the wins
I don't really understand why we don't
talk more about if you want to project
that into the future and you could you
want to think how can this technology
help me in the future addressing some of
the big security issues think about
authentication you know these very bad
password hygiene that we all have you
know reusing the same password across
different web sites I don't want to you
know who does that who doesn't do that
we know that a way to solve this and one
of the important way to solve this will
be behavioral authentication you know
making sense of the different signals
that we share with our devices with our
watches how we look how we sound how we
handled your device our if we combine
all these signals together using these
systems we're able to identify you by a
factor 10,000 more accurate than a
normal digit password when we're able to
identify you so precisely we're then
able to authenticate you sometimes
hopefully in real time so that when I'm
using my mobile phone and I access the
core Google services you know my phone
authenticates me to these systems when I
pass my phone to my son or automatically
the access rights
down to Pokemon go this is the kind of
technology that is not future music this
is the kind you know proof of concepts
out there as DK as there you know and
the trusted testers and we are working
with partners so that of course they
will long the road is long there's a lot
of privacy concerns a lot of discussions
to have with the community and with
society but this is these are the kind
of things that large cloud providers and
Google specifically will be embedding in
their technology as they as we grow
right and you will be benefitting
directly from this as we grow I'm
linking this slide with the concept of
security by design it's fantastic that
you know the regulator imposes now
security by design and when you will be
reviewing the gdpr you will see this
term security by design think already
about evolving this design you know how
can this design adapt and evolve to the
to the - to the landscape this is what
these technologies will allow the second
concept that I brought up this morning
was to control over the entire stack
okay the biggest concern of if you ask a
chief security officer today and
remember asking the question - chief
security officer at Google what his what
is keeping him what is keeping him awake
at night one of the things that he will
bring up he or she will bring up is the
supply chain of the components how are
you sure that the components you bring
into your systems in your organization
are secure because of the size that
large cloud platforms and Google in
particular we've been adamant on this on
this topic because of the size we
operate at we have the luxury of
designing our own hardware our own chips
you know controlling and designing our
own custom operating systems and
throughout the different layers of the
stack all the way to the mobile
interface we have kept a very high level
of control I mentioned this morning how
this allows for faster or relatively
faster incident detection and relative
easier incident remediation again when
you think of the words of the regulator
today you know bridge
if occation how fast can you react
having that kind of transparency and
homogeneity in the system is something
that will play in your favor actually I
want to talk about this like before I
will get to the other one after one of
the important layers here that that is
most illustrative is the storage layer
how do we store the data and how do we
do we protect the data when when we
store it data at Google is when you
enter information in a Gmail or in a
Google Docs before you even send the
email or share the document the the data
that you have typed in is instantly
chunked into pieces several kilobytes to
a couple of megabytes in size maximum
each of these pieces is replicated at
least three times on the same server and
at least three times in the same data
center sorry and at least across two
data centers across the world this is
how it goes all the time when you use
Gmail or Google Docs each of these
chunks of data is then encrypted with a
data encryption key the data encryption
key is located very close to the chunk
so that it can you know decrypt very
fast but of course there are so many
millions hundreds of millions of data
encryption keys each of these data
encryption keys is encrypted with a key
encryption key and the key encryption
keys are stored in the key store and
there are replicates of the key store in
approximately 10,000 locations around
the world
all access to the key store is
controlled by access control lists and
logged so it is we used to never
communicate this before we this is how
we're able to explain to financial
regulators and other regulators you know
of the world how we were sure that we
were in control of who is accessing your
data because it is virtually impossible
to go through these two layers of
encryption
without it is impossible to go to go
through these two layers of encryption
without accessing a little key store and
leaving a trace in the in the log then I
spoke about the infrastructure and how
having your data replicated across a
global infrastructure 15 data centers
across the world for in Europe you know
I mentioned them this morning Finland
Ireland Holland and Belgium there's a
slight competition between Holland and
Belgium at the moment for who has the
biggest data center so even at Google
yeah so and two more coming actually
very soon in Europe so an expansion of
this network but the size of these data
centers is not the most important piece
of information I find very relevant
information is the connection of these
dark fibers that connect the data
centers proprietary fibers we lay out
our own cables through the ocean of take
part into consortiums
where we have a direct control on the
cables and that makes us you know puts
us in a very good position to address
latency I mention latency is very
important when you offer a collaboration
solution but also in terms of security
we are very much in control of our
destiny you know for many of our
customers this is a critical decision
point we talk publicly about the
Hollywood the Hollywood industry is a
big fan of Google cloud at the moment
they are you know using a lot of our
computing powers and storage powers you
can understand how sensitive you know
any movie is and they do not want this
to leak and how aggressively you know
they can be attacked and they they you
know having the benefits of this these
encryption these own the proprietary
pipes you know through the ocean self
encrypted encrypted under our own
control is very interesting to them so
this is for the connection between the
data centers the yellow points that you
see there represents our Google front
ends so the connection points between
the Google infrastructure and the public
Internet and this gives you an idea of
the amount of
options we can play with when you come
under DDoS attack for example it is then
very easy and it happens actually
automatically to load balance the
traffic from any of those Google front
ends to make sure that you remain online
even though one half of the world is
being under attack this is the kind of
infrastructure that allows a large
public cloud provider like Google to aim
for what we called zero recovery point
objective so a recovery point objective
of zero which means in case of major
catastrophe zero data loss and zero
recovery time objective which means in
case of major catastrophe instant
failover you do not see anything every
year Google at least every year Google
simulates major catastrophes so we shut
down portions of the world you have
never noticed any of these drills in the
nine years I've been at Google and I'm
twelve twelve hours per day in front of
my of these tools once I was thinking
wow this is there is something going on
and indeed you know I never knew exactly
what it was but there was there was
something there was something so this
infrastructure are highly redundant and
are used to to offer that lastly and
very important when we switch to the
compliance discussion this is the
infrastructure that allows us to aim to
deliver the same level of security for
everybody in the world you know you
might be tired sometimes of the
idealistic stance of Google but this is
very important to the teams there is no
way that will offer more security to a
German than to a Pakistani or to a US
citizen
okay we want to offer the same level of
security for everybody and so whenever
we hear you want to have data here and
there we like first of all you might not
know what you wish you know locating
data might not increase your security
secondly you know this is really not
what we are aiming to deliver to the
world quickly another thing that Google
has been allowed to
has been able to solve is the biggest
problem of the chief security officers
today is the access to human resources
how do you convince the right brains to
come and work on these tough problems in
your organization's you know even if
you're a large bank in your country of
course there are there are there are
several that you will but you know we
have a tremendous advantage there and
even though we have many of these
researchers in-house working on these
tough problems we acutely know that it
is not seven hundred people that will
solve security on the web and so these
guys are constantly collaborating with
the research community actually before
having worked alongside these guys I
realized they do not come - they did not
come to work for Google they come to
work for disc John you know who was
their guru when they were doing their
PhD and they want to keep on solving
that problem if disc on John goes to
another company you know probably they
will follow the importance you know this
community lives as a separate life and
that's an understatement
so one of the things that they are
really proud of is the vulnerability
reward program where we actively
encourage anybody around the world to
attack our systems many of the questions
we receive from our institutional
customers is under what condition can we
pen test you any condition it's all fair
game give it your best shot the email
that we send to people that ask us this
question is literally three lines give
it your best shot we don't want to know
anything the only thing is if you find a
vulnerability tell us otherwise we can't
pay you we've paid already more than
four million dollars in rewards the the
researcher that received the most money
received two hundred thousand dollars if
they decide to give this to charity you
know we we basically double the amount
so and believe it or not as many of them
give these things to charity so so this
open collaboration model is the last
thing I want to say because it's in the
world of security it's a very important
point this is so at this point I hope we
have not exaggerated on the technology
aspects and we're not reaching at the
Newseum point I want to spin to pivot
I want to pivot to compliance
and and and tell you what are the tools
that we give you okay to increase that
confidence in the system this is
probably the most important slide of the
entire presentation the only thing you
really really need to remember if
anything is when you sign a contract
with a cloud provider would be Google
cloud Amazon Microsoft or any other you
are being defined as a data controller
in control of the data and the cloud
provider is being defined as a data
processor and the data processor may not
use your data for any other purpose than
deliver you the service than you paid
for this is a cornerstone of the GDP our
cornerstone of you know all these
contracts and a very very important
notion that also explains while there
will be no advertising by Google you
know or no usage by Google of the data
you put into into our system because it
is contractually written just like in
any other contract before you write into
the contracts you will have access to
all the information that the regulator's
now expects you to have before you sign
a contract what is the exact location of
the data so you receive the location of
data centers we may not be able to tell
you in which in which data center the
data is but it is in some of these data
centers the subprocessors you know who
are the sub processors the availability
of the systems is available through
public dashboards so you can see at any
given point of time when when these
systems are available when they have
been down and you can make your own
assessment there is it sufficient or not
and importantly you know these
certifications all large cloud providers
have undergone now the major
certifications you will recognize if you
familiar to that world 27001 which
certifies for computing computing
security
27:17 for cloud computing 27:18 for
handling of PII so these are the gold
standards on these topics the second
layer are the soccer audit reports are
very stringent very well recognized you
can access we provide you access to the
sock to reports and
so this the sock three is public you can
you can obtain it the sock 2 is 210
pages of granular controls it is also
available for our customers under NDA so
if you really want to check every single
control security control it is available
I just want to stop on to one badge
which is the FedRAMP badge because it's
a clear differentiator between Google
and the other cloud providers all cloud
providers major cloud providers have
achieved this certification which allows
clouds to deliver services to the
federal agencies of the United States
government including defense and so yes
we have many defense customers using you
know Google cloud and having the data
onto onto the infrastructure what is
specific about Google certification is
Google is the only provider that
certified the entire infrastructure as
opposed to our competitors who certified
subset of the infrastructure so they
have built specific farms that have
received that badges that badge and
these these farms of servers that are
serving you know the these federal
agencies and and delivering that kind of
security when you engage with Google you
receive exactly the same level of
security that we guarantee to Rockwell
Collins for example a major defense
contractor of the United States or there
is ma for that matter you have the
information you get to the moment where
you sign the contracts and there are a
few things that you really have to pay
attention about attention to the scope
of processing I mentioned absolutely
demanded by the regulators today that
the processor may not touch the data for
any other purpose contractually
committed intellectual property you keep
you know the intellectual property of
your data seems normal when you think
about machine learning and the
intelligence that you will develop using
machine learning tools on your big data
sets very important that you also keep
that knowledge and that doesn't come
into anyone else's hands portability you
know when you have developed 30
petabytes of data in 10 years how do you
walk out are we going to help you how
many trucks of hard drives do we have to
bring you know to the data centers these
are literal questions that are being
asked now with with some prospects
very important is the access to data
from third party jurisdiction what
happens if an Indian foreign judge asks
for data of one of your employees you
have to get back to the concept of
controller and processor in the world of
the cloud as opposed to the consumer
world of Google in the world of a cloud
we are in a very comfortable position
when the judge comes to us we say hey we
are only processors you should ask the
controller and we redirect the request
from the judge to you and you decide how
you want to go with that request most of
the time you will want to collaborate
with justice sometimes you might not
want to collaborate with justice it is
really up to you the moment you feedback
to us a formal legal decision that you
refuse this is where it stops for us you
keep on discussing with the judge and
with the and with justice so of course
there are some fringe cases where we are
not allowed to tell your employee or you
you know that we get requests for the
data pedophilia organized crime drug
smuggling imminent crime into an
investigation these are typical
situations where the lawmaker has
provided that there will be no misstep
to impede into the execution of justice
generally the more regulated the
customer I engage with the more they
know that you know if I engage with a
bank and there are lawyers or from the
bank in the room they just nod and they
say yes proceed you know we also have
these that probably have these cases as
often as we do and this is this is you
know we are not above the law we do
publish the number of cases I need to
hurry up I'm out of time I hope I'm not
too slow we do publish all the cases
where we get these requests in what we
call the transparency reports if you're
interested into that you google
transparency reports all the large
players have done this by now also and
you can find trance
see reports from Twitter and other
organizations but you find by country by
year how many requests have been
executed you know it's interesting when
you I presented yesterday in Germany and
you know the Germans are very very
adamant on how much America can look
into their systems and I pointed to this
to the year.22 to the reports and said
you should go and check out because
America made thirteen thousand requests
lights last year Germany made close to
ten thousand and France which is also
very reactive made close to nine
thousand so all of a sudden you realize
how important it is to put your data
into a an infrastructure that wants to
defend everybody the same way
independently of the local perception of
who wants to access what data went so
security and our commitments to keep the
certifications that we talked about
throughout the duration of the agreement
we don't just achieve a certification
let you sign and then drop it and of
course audit rights is a very important
topic depending on the sector where you
operate in and you know your lawyers
will be more or less adamant on these
clothes and but more in in in summary
you know these contracts allow you to
come and verify that we do what we say
we do of course we don't like to have
six million customers walking across our
data centers so this is not what is
happening you will not have access to
four data centers but we have mechanisms
okay which allow you to check i have
access to the detailed reports and then
propose some new controls if some
controls have not been done and you're
not not satisfied with the audit you can
inject you know new controls that will
be included into the into the audit form
for the next cycle at this point we've
reached the European discussion will it
even fit with the European law and here
it's always useful I find to summarize
what the European law actually says
still today the handling of personal
data in Europe is regulated by a
directive of 95 1995 that very
specifically says it is not allowed to
export European data unless adequate
safety man
are in place quoting the law probably
hopefully exactly sorry should've
reviewed the text before better thing
but these adequate safety measures are
summarized in the safe harbor which was
invalidated last year replaced by
privacy shield privacy shield is heavily
debated European activist thinks it's
not okay
Trump administration things is not okay
at least these two agree on this topic
but it doesn't really matter because all
large cloud providers of course rely on
privacy shield as one of the mechanisms
that is fully you know give the full
title to export data but all cloud
providers use the model contract clauses
and these are 12 clauses that have been
devised by the data privacy authorities
of Europe and they proposed model
clauses that all cloud providers should
add to their contract if these clauses
are added to the contract there is no
more discussion you may export data
personal data outside of Europe so these
model contract clauses come into two
shapes I wanted to check what slider had
behind and now you won't go back okay
either standard model contract clauses
or model contract clauses that have been
approved by the common opinion process
and the common opinion process is a
process through which the cloud
providers proposes is modeled current
cloak model contract clause to the
regulator and the regulator officially
approves these clauses and they are
binding and there is no way a data
privacy authority around Europe can then
change his opinion and say oh by the way
no you can't use Google and you have to
keep data in the sky in my country when
you use Google you know this is a
binding opinion including for for Norway
then comes the GDP are the GDP are will
replace the directive of 1995 and it is
very important for all of you to receive
that commitment at the GDP at the
deadline of GDP ours coming
okay bye mm May 2018 this new regulation
will be enforced and what the gdpr does
it increases a lot the power of the data
privacy authorities to inspect what is
being done with the data what you do
with your users data and your own police
data and your customers data what we do
with your data and all of your
stakeholders data so the data privacy
authorities have gained a lot of power
and they have also gained very
impressive tools in terms of fines that
can go up to 4% of the yearly global
revenue of your company per incident
okay some banks have many incidents some
anything as many incidents no throwing
anything on banks here so a lot of
emotions in general on the positive side
I I personally think that you know in
usually Europe is always lagging behind
the United States when it comes to
digital revolution digital
transformation for once that we do
something that really matters and that
really the rest of the world is looking
at we should be proud as European of the
GDP are and you should we should really
embrace this as an opportunity to raise
the trust of you know our entire society
in the digital world and use this
legislation to accelerate adoption this
is by the way what we see now we see an
acceleration of the demand for cloud
services because of the increased risk
okay and and some many stakeholders see
an opportunity to key for the GDP are is
that the GDP are does not changes the
rules for international data transfers
so again Google article 46 of the GDP
are because this is a very emotional and
you know people have completely
different opinions and ideas about it
the text is there article 46 of the GDP
are very clearly states a controller
processor may transfer personal data to
a third country or international
incision if the controller processor has
provided appropriate safeguards which
can take the shape of something like the
privacy shield model
tract clauses or new mechanisms like
code of conducts and certification
mechanisms that will come into place
when the gdpr is launched and Google is
actively engaged into these other
processes to make sure that even if
privacy shield Falls even if model
contract clauses would fall you know
there would be other mechanisms
available I don't think I want to repeat
the advice I gave this morning about
segmenting your decision process into a
technical risk assessment a legal risk
assessment a political risk assessment
is your country or any of the countries
you are active in engage in to data
localization legislation like Russia
like China you know and others in the
Middle East
you need to have a cloud provider that
can at the same time deliver the service
in these countries and respond protect
your information in these countries and
of course the political the cultural
risk is the first the fourth one you
might be forced to keep data in country
because of cultural reasons this is
perfectly normal
but make sure that you'd make a
distinction between these four layers
when you make this to this decision
because sometimes things get confused
and you might think you might be taking
the wrong technical and legal decision
because of a cultural decision I will go
quickly over these ones because I want
to I would touched upon this this
morning so and I want to have more time
on the personal tools again what I was
trying to convey this morning was in the
areas of responsibility that you keep
even as in terms of security and
compliance even as you move to the cloud
and you know if you use infrastructure
as a service you still have a lot of
things that your customers and your
regulators will be expecting you to do
in terms of it you can't benefit from
technologies I spoke about
authentication strong authentication
these security keys and 2-step
authentication are very important to
easily improve your security stance
encryption
one of the benefits of moving to the
cloud and to moving to Google's cloud
specifically you benefit from encryption
out of the box you can either trust us
to manage your keys if you don't you can
manage your keys yourself and if you
don't trust us to even have access to
the keys you can also you know bring
your own keys and we don't have any
access to the data at all don't lose the
keys this is serious I mean our guys are
really panicked about customers losing
the keys and then the media going Google
lost the data you know and then we
talked about DLP API the example that I
gave very briefly this morning about you
as an employee organizing a party with
your chip for your children through your
corporate email and then this being
archived in the corporate archive and
then it's coming back ten years ago ten
years later and the regulator asking
your company why did you keep the
addresses email addresses of these
children in your in your email is a real
question you know we received from a
customer this is the real situation this
is to tell how complex this is going to
become and this is where technology and
advanced technology you know can really
help you and you have you had a demo
this morning but this is an animation of
the DLP API
you know scanning through a live chat
bot also you know when you see the feed
coming in as the the credit card number
is being typed you know it is being
flagged and so this technology can be
applied you can think of plugging this
to our api's into your into your
technology and addressing some of the
big challenges that are coming that are
coming ahead I want to summarize who
knows this - all right this is this is
Netherlands they all knew you know
everything already so if you don't know
these two it's funny because there's no
I'm not going to make regional
distinction this is going the wrong way
if you don't know these two go to these
two as soon as you can type your email
address in okay and see how many times
your login credentials have been put up
for sale on the web if they are out
there and you're reusing the password
was associated to that login at the time
you have a problem you should not reuse
your password on different properties to
help you do that
install password alert which is a Chrome
extension on Chrome that will
automatically detect whenever you reuse
your password and you know stop you from
doing that if you install this in your
organization in your enterprise
it will also warn your administrator
that you have reused your corporate
password for another property and it
will immediately deactivate your
password at Google
we don't change passwords every 60 90
days I haven't changed my passwords in
many years because I was called three
times and I am not caught anymore I
never reuse my corporate passwords and I
know it very well and that's what you
need and then lastly you know second
step authentication if you are not using
second step authentication today and
you're still relying on your password to
protect you online you're not acting
responsibly you should activate second
step authentication and you should
activate hardware-based you know we I
don't do I put the Fido logo the Fido is
a global alliance in which we
participated that developed the
standards and this is Fido enabled keys
allow you to bring a second factor that
is unfishable it's basically a
cryptographic signature that leaves your
computer to the servers and as opposed
to standard to say potent occasion when
you have to type in a code this code can
be key logged this code can be captured
by a man-in-the-middle attack you know
the second factor traditional second
factor has weaknesses that are being
abused increasingly now and this is how
we protect Google now for the last four
years and this is available on Gmail you
can order one of those on Amazon could
between 6 and 15 dollars you receive it
you activate it you pair it to Gmail and
then you have a key for your home a key
for your car and a key for your data and
you don't really mind if your password
disappears any questions I don't know if
we have time focus we don't have
you